we now are aware of more than 100 us service
members who have been diagnosed with traumatic
brain injuries. These are those same traumatic
brain injuries
Donald Trump previously described as not serious
headaches. All as a result of that January
8th arrange Ian missiles, a attack on the
military base in Iraq. The Pentagon said yesterday,
the exact number is 109 service members who
have been diagnosed the most recent number
was 64 but remember that the number initially
started far lower at 10 which was never really
a believable number and we'll get to that
in a moment. Now we're not saying these hundred
and nine brain injuries are the most serious
brain injuries. Some are mild, about 70% of
the service members are or are soon going
to be back to work. But remember that Donald
rump, Donald Trump wrote these off as headaches,
cadet bone spurs deciding that these are mere
headaches. Remember this?
Awesome. Here's the, here's how the president
described it when he was asked about these
injuries.
I heard that they had headaches and a couple
of other things, but I would say, yeah, and
I can report it is not very serious.
And Republicans actually ran interference
for Trump. Here is sick, vile Senator Tom
cotton, truly one of the worst saying, well
you, Trump's not really dismissing them as
headaches. He's describing them as headaches
and that of course is perfectly fine to do
so. I think veterans groups are calling for
the president to apologize. Should he apologize
for calling it? Nothing serious. He's not
dismissing their injuries. He's describing
their headaches and not very serious. I think
he's describing their injuries. He's not dismissing
their injuries. Head injuries can be on anywhere.
I don't consider them very serious. Well that's
like saying that having a flesh wound is not
very serious. And I know you're a veteran
and I know you know a veteran separate from
TBI as Dubai. Don't you think it's serious
and that the president may need to apologize.
I mean if it isn't, if they are in Fe, all
of these injuries are not serious. If they're
on the less serious side of the scale than
the severe traumatic side of the scale. The
president is just describing what happened
to name is not dismissing them.
Nice people. Right? So when we talk about
a brain injury, TBI, traumatic brain injury,
it can vary in severity, but it's not a headache
that we know for sure. Sometimes they happen
in sports. We know football, this is a big
issue. Hockey, it can be a big issue. There's
even questions about younger kids using their
head to hit a soccer ball, potentially causing
a sort of a similar dynamic. It can happen
in a car accident when a victim's a passenger's
head hits the windshield of the vehicle and
they happen to people in the military. The
most notable thing here is that from day one
we knew that they weren't giving us the real
number. They said, well, it's 10 or 11 and
that number was clearly BS. And uh, the phrasing
of how they gave us that first number suggested
that it was not 10 or 11 we knew it couldn't
be the right number.
And then it became something like maybe 35
and then we had the number 64 and now the
number is 109 because they are lying, they
are lying all the time about everything period.
And by the way, we hear about service member
injuries because we're hearing about it from
the U S Pentagon and the number is now 109.
Obviously there were also non-American non-service
members injured and we simply haven't heard
about that. Civilians and others concussed
by the missiles that resulted from Donald
Trump's assassination of Kaseem Solemani.
There were known to be hundreds of people
in the area if not more. They weren't all
service members and we may never even know
the full number, uh, as it applies here. My
question to you is, do you think that the
average Trump is who believes the lies they
are told by this administration ever gets
like a shot of shame or a shot of humiliation
or a tinge of embarrassment from realizing
that they've been duped, that they've been
had, that they've been bamboozled on everything,
right?
And now we're talking about brain injuries
and Trump dismissing them as headaches. But
it could be about the wall. It could be about
taxes, it could be about trade, it could be
about growth, it could be about whatever.
Do ever feel that tinge of something or will
they never get it? And there's something,
I alluded to this earlier and I think it bears
repeating here. There's something in here
that is similar between Trump's lies to the
people who get tricked into following a cult
leader who says, again, the world's ending
on April 21st or, uh, there will come a day
where we all need to drink a poisoned a Koolaid
or whatever the case may be. And then the
prophecy fails, or the justification falls
flat. But they still follow the dear leader
because they either somehow rationalize it
or they've put, for some people it's that
they've put so much of their own identity
in with whatever ideology and the term ideology
in some cases is not the right one with whatever,
uh, talking points have been presented to
them associated with this leader and they
can never back out.
And behavioral psychology might call it a
cognitive dissonance of sorts. In the cult
world, they might call it brainwashing. There
are different words that would apply depending
on how you see this. But increasingly the
cult analysis I'm including, we had a guest
on, um, uh, Steven Hasson who has been studying
this quite a bit. Increasingly, the cult analysis
is the most appropriate one for talking about
what it is that is going on with the average
Trumpist. Tell me what you think. Is it more
cultish? Is it more cognitive dissonance?
Is it out of ignorance? Is it something else
altogether? I want to hear from you maybe
via Twitter, at D, Pacman.